10 il y avait environ 200 satellites en
orbite en 2021 on en compte quatre mille
et en 2030 il n'y en aura plus de 100
milles autour de la terre le secteur
spatial est un domaine stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
moscou lundi kiev le lendemain emmanuel
macron rencontrera en personne ses
homologues russe et ukrainien la semaine
prochaine une médias pour tenter de
résoudre le conflit qui opposait deux
pays selon washington la russie
envisagerait de filmer une fausse
attaque ukrainienne prétexte pour
envahir son voisin le kremlin appelle à
ne pas croire sur parole les
affirmations américaines
[Musique]
moscou qui s'opposent à l'expansion de
l'otan et qui peut compter sur le
soutien de pékin le président russe est
en chine pour l'ouverture des jeux
olympiques d'hiver il s'est entretenu
avec le président chez jean ping dans
une déclaration commune les deux
dirigeants dénoncent l'influencé
américaine et le rôle des alliances
militaires occidentales en europe comme
en asie et les juges déstabilisatrices
[Musique]
la police confronté à une vague de
suicides sur le seul mois de janvier
douze policiers se sont donné la mort en
france la profession est confrontée à ce
fléau depuis plusieurs décennies le
ministre de l'intérieur recevait en fin
de journée syndicats et associations on
en parle avec nos invités dans ce
journal
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
en pleine crise diplomatique entre la
russie et l'ukraine emmanuel la macro
francs dos donc le rôle de médiateur
depuis plusieurs semaines les
occidentaux accusent moscou d'une
offensive imminente en ukraine sans
apporter de preuves washington affirme
désormais que la russie envisagerait de
filmer une fausse attaque ukrainienne
contre elles prétextent créé de toutes
pièces pour envahir son voisin selon les
états unis allégations balayée par les
autorités russes le président français
30 tentera lui la semaine prochaine
d'abord c'est une désescalade la
correspondance à moscou faisait un
goffman
après trois entretiens par téléphone une
rencontre en bonne et due forme le
kremlin confirmés et les pourparlers à
moscou le 7 février entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron ces
négociations prévue lundi à la
mi-journée au kremlin seront suivis
d'une conférence de presse selon dmitri
peskov porte parole du président russe
il sera question des garanties de
sécurité mutuelle entre la russie et
l'otan l'a dit mur poutine compte
expliquer la position et les
préoccupations russes la question de la
non expansion de l'otan vers l'est sujet
essentiel pour la russie a été notamment
soutenue par le leader chinois dans une
déclaration commune publiée ce vendredi
4 février mitri peskov a également réagi
aux déclarations du département d'état
américain sur la préparation par moscou
de fausses vidéos visant à justifier une
offensive russe en ukraine je vous
propose d'écouter je recommande de ne
pas croire qui que ce soit sur parole
sur tout le département d'état américain
quand il s'agit de telles questions
plus tôt dans la journée c'est le chef
de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
qui avait qualifié de délire les
déclarations du département d'état
américain écoutez j'ai lu j'ai regardé
sur internet des déclarations du
département d'état selon lesquelles la
russie préparerait une fausse vidéo
montrant une attaque de militaires
ukrainien contre le dombass ce genre
d'histoire sont de plus en plus
nombreuses chaque jour et sont un délire
évident pour n'importe quel politologue
ayant de l'expérience selon le kremlin
le président russe doit rencontrer le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz qui
viendra à son tour à moscou le 15
février le kremlin n'exclus pas non
rencontre avec le président ukrainien
wladimir zelensky alors comment analyser
le déplacement des manuels maquereau en
russie et en ukraine leurs gardes régis
le sommier et grand reporter chez arte
france
ya une légitimité en tant que président
de la france a mené des discussions mais
également au nom de l'europe donc il ya
une initiative intéressante qui est fait
pour tenter de débloquer la situation il
faut voir que d'un point de vue du point
de vue français du point de vue des
manuels macro il y a tout à gagner dans
cette histoire d'abord essayer de tenter
cette diplomatie traditionnelle de la
france qui est la diplomatie plat de la
puissance médiatrice de celle qui
essayent de tenter ya cette voix cette
voix française je vous dit d'essayer qui
est toujours le rôle traditionnel de la
france ces deux de commandes être sept
puissances médiatrices qui apporte des
solutions qui apportent éventuellement
un dialogue
autre que le dialogue finalement entre
les etats-unis et la russie qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent en fait ce convoi entre
anthony blinken skis et de sergueï
lavrov essentiellement c'est un accord
pour dialoguer mais en réalité tout le
monde campe sur des positions et il n'y
a pas beaucoup lu d'avancé emmanuel
macron évidemment n'est absolument pas
naïve cette cette visite ne se fait pas
du tout au hasard elle est le fruit
d'une volonté de sa part peut-être de
peser dans les relations internationales
mais il ya chez lui évidemment la
question d'élection de sa réélection
derrière
parmi les propositions russes en vue
d'une résolution du conflit la fin de
l'élargissement de l'otan à l'est
propositions et vision soutenue par la
chine en marge de l'ouverture des jeux
olympiques d'hiver auquel il a assisté
vladimir poutine s'est entretenu avec le
président chinois xi jinping une
déclaration commune a été publié dans la
foulée les détails avec maelys d'estrées
le sommet chine russie organisée ce
vendredi à pékin a confirmé que les deux
pays sont plus soudés que jamais lors de
sa rencontre avec si jean ping vladimir
poutine a mis en exergue l'esprit
d'amitié et le partenariat stratégique
qui unissent leurs deux pays une
alliance qui transparaît également dans
le communiqué publié ce vendredi par
moscou et pékin ils y exposent leur
point de vue partagé sur plusieurs
dossiers y compris l'extension vers le
temps les parties s'oppose à
l'élargissement de l'otan et appelle
l'alliance atlantique a abandonné les
approches idéologisé de l'époque de la
guerre froide à respecter la
souveraineté la sécurité les intérêts
des autres pays ainsi que la diversité
de leurs modes civilisationnel culturel
et historique
lesquin réitère son soutien aux
propositions de moscou visant à établir
des garanties de sécurité en europe une
fois de plus russes et chinois rejette
l'idée d'un modèle démocratique et nick
les tentatives de certains pays
d'imposer leurs normes démocratiques à
d'autres de sa tribu le monopole
concernant l'évaluation du niveau de
conformité aux critères démocratiques de
tracer des lignes de séparation sur des
bases idéologiques sont en fait un
exemple de piétinement de la démocratie
et de dévoiement de son esprit et de ses
vraies valeurs et carré moscou dénonce
également jeu cycle influences négatives
pour la paix et la stabilité dans la
région de la stratégie indo pacifique
des états unis et se disent préoccupés
par la création de locus l'alliance
entre les états unis le royaume uni et
l'australie tant dans leurs paroles que
dans leurs écrits la russie et la chine
font ainsi front commun face à la
thalassocratie anglo saxon et ses alliés
occidentaux
nouveau coup dur pour boris johnson en
24 heures le premier ministre
britannique a été lâché par 100
conseillers boris johnson qui a eu beau
présenter ses excuses faire des
promesses la sphère du parti gates n'en
finit pas de faire des remous ce
scandale des fêtes organisées au 10
downing street sans plan confinement
dans le pays on dit c'est la survie
politique menacée mais pour françois
pour les mathis journaliste spécialiste
des institutions européennes il ne faut
pas sous-estimer sa capacité à rebondir
mais il faut pas sous-estimer non plus
le personnage pour hilton est quelqu'un
qui a aussi l'habitude de rebondir mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il est dans
une situation très délicate délicate
pourquoi parce que le parti conservateur
a changé et le parti conservateur peut
ne pas faire de cadeaux comme il n'a pas
fait de cadeau d'ailleurs à une certaine
époque avec une certaine margaret
thatcher voire même plus récemment avec
theresa may qui avait tant gagner des
élections et qui s'est fait éjecter du
parti de down et c'est tout ça parce que
ont jugé qu'elle était incapable de
mener à bien les négociations du break
site alors que va-t-il se passer
actuellement il y à une enquête qui est
menée par scotland yard par la police
pour savoir exactement qui est la
réalité des fêtes donc tout est un peu
soumis aux résultats de cette enquête à
tel point que le haut fonctionnaire qui
avait chargé notamment de faire ses
premières révélations s'est replié à
accepter finalement de s'en remettre aux
résultats de cette enquête on devrait
connaître dans les prochains jours
d'autant que cette enquête n'a pas été
publié johnson espère effectivement
convaincre la plupart de ses collègues
de tenir de tenir coûte que coûte
un ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin recevait sur cette journée
syndicats et associations de policiers
la police
confronté à une vague de suicides dans
ses rangs depuis le début de l'année
douze policiers se sont donné la mort en
france le problème date pas d'hier les
causes sont multiples les profils
différents et les syndicats alertent
depuis des années sur ce phénomène
dramatique
on en parle avec pierre cabaret députés
et la république en marche en haute
garonne est has been taibi mer un pcf de
ce temps soutien de jean-luc mélenchon
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france has been taibi
ce fléau des suicides dans la police
même si on le rappelle toutes les
histoires personnelles sont sont très
différentes les unes des autres est-ce
qu'il est quand même aussi le symbole
dans ma lettre au sein de la profession
oui il est évidemment c'est un bol d'un
mal être qui malheureusement de ne pas
d'hier on sait déjà depuis
malheureusement depuis de très
nombreuses années que nous assistons
ahmad ezz assez profond a je dirais à
désarroi de beaucoup de policiers
permettez moi quand même d'avoir une
pensée très émue auprès des familles des
deux policiers c'est énorme depuis le
début janvier la la disparition de douze
policiers
suicide c'est énorme donc souvent les
suicides ont lieu soit dans leurs lieux
je tairai personnel familial peut-être
certains hauts lieux au moment où
travaille ou pas donc il ya vraiment il
ya véritablement un malaise il ya un
malaise qui est à la fois je dirais
qui est clairement de montrer que la
police l'institution policière ne
protège pas assez de ces policiers et
psychologiquement mais également sur une
démarche je dirais beaucoup plus
collectif beaucoup plus je dirais
rassurante
et forcément
ccc disparition terrible
doit en tous les cas nous rappeler qu'il
ya nécessité de mon point de vue à
refonder je dirais estimant dans des
grands axes notre police de la
république c'est une police républicaine
ou police qui est au service
des citoyennes et des citoyens de ce
pays et on a bien sûr bien évidemment
besoin de cette police le policier
proche de nos populations en particulier
dans les zones où nous manquons
cruellement de policier c'est le cas ici
instant largement seine-saint-denis donc
donc voilà donc face à ceux à cette
situation générée insoutenable
humainement est extrêmement difficile à
la fois pour les familles des policiers
décédés mais également pour tous les
policiers qui travaillent sur le terrain
et qui sont confrontés à beaucoup de
difficultés et parfois on leur demande
de faire du chiffre on leur demande
d'atteindre des objectifs qui sont
parfois il réalisable parce que parce
que la police a besoin
a besoin de travailler dans la durée a
besoin de travailler aussi avec des
missions beaucoup plus large qui ne sont
pas que des missions de sécurité et
garantir la sûreté de nos concitoyens
même si c'est important mais elle a
besoin aussi travaillé dans le domaine
de la prévention travaille dans le
domaine aussi je dirais de la relation
avec avec des sites où justement pierre
cabaret qu'elle annonçait ce qu'on peut
attendre ce soir du ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'entretient donc
visiblement toujours avec associations
et syndicats de policiers qu est ce qui
a été fait au cours de ce quinquennat
aussi pour accompagner
ces policiers dans l'exercice de leur
profession
bonsoir vous me permettrez d'abord de
présenter toutes mes condoléances à la
fois aux familles et à chaque policier
aussi parce que il ne faut pas oublier
que chaque policier qui décède et
entouré et a été entouré par ses
collègues
donc
je d'abord il a été fait énormément de
choses et dernièrement encore on a
renforcé à la fois le matériel à la fois
le la reconnaissance salariale mais ce
sont des personnes qui effectivement
manque de reconnaissance je crois que
lorsque on a une population qui peut
passer de l'applaudissement à dire les
violences policières et quand j'entends
le maire de stains vous permettrait
monsieur le maire d'être très étonnée
par votre demande alors que pendant très
longtemps vous avez vous même exprimé
ces violences policières de façon
déraisonnée parce que pour moi elle vise
et et déraisonné cette expression et
déraisonné voilà donc la première chose
deuxième chose je crois que depuis cinq
ans il ya eu une prise en charge et une
prise en conscience de du mal être de la
police c'est très compliqué de répondre
de façon
immédiate mais les psychologues qui sont
là il y en a 120 aujourd'hui on aura
d'autres prochainement
sont là pour recueillir leurs leur mal
être et comment alors je vais je veux
dire je commence c'est un policier pour
exprimer son mal être auprès de sa
famille mon fils a été policier pendant
onze ans et c'est vrai qu'il a commencé
à 22 ans
c'est très très difficile
ils vivent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles parce qu'il voit
la misère ils voient la mort il voit ce
qui tend notre société est terriblement
difficile de se représenter et en plus
quand on a 22 ans et ils me racontaient
ce qu'ils voyaient élevé il avait quand
même c'est un exutoire de raconter à son
père en tout cas à ses parents ce qu'ils
voyaient un policier quand il a une
trentaine d'années qui hantent il rentre
chez lui quand il à ses enfants quand
ses enfants eux mêmes ne disent pas à
l'école que son papa et policiers parce
que finalement à l'école on dénigre
beaucoup les policiers aussi et au ronde
qu'on essaie de cacher le métier bien
acquis va-t-il le dire sinon à ses
collègues et je crois que là-dessus
c'est très important que ses collègues
puissent recueillir ces paroles et de
façon un peu plus forte et que les
syndicats soient plus directement
concernés par tout cela et je crois que
on à frédéric veaux qui est très
compétent on a un ministère de
l'intérieur qui est extrêmement objectif
là dessus qui prend des décisions qui
celle qui sait faire des choix et je
pense que à l'issue de ces réunions on
va aborder s'annonce non pas des
annonces mais des actes parce que vous
savez on peut toujours pas faire des
paroles mais la politique en ai plein le
plein de parole donc maintenant il faut
des actes je voudrais souligner aussi
que
les élus ont un rôle extrêmement
important moi je ne lâche pas les
policiers je ne les ai jamais lâché je
vais les rencontrer régulièrement je
vais avec eux régulièrement et ça va de
la ronde à l'apéritif avec eux et on
apprend beaucoup de choses et vous savez
on apprend tellement de choses qu'on a
envie de les recevoir l'assemblée et 7
et les recevoir l'assemblée c'est
peut-être pas pour recevoir toujours
gelé plus haut gradé qui vont nous
raconter et nous dire leur vie et c'est
important aussi que de les recevoir mais
aussi laisser la place à ceux qui sont
dans la rue ou dans les bureaux qui
reçoivent les personnes qui sont dans la
détresse et je crois que là-dessus
j'aimerais proposer à l'assemblée
nationale prochainement de pouvoir
recevoir de façon anonyme ces policiers
pour qu'ils nous racontent leur vécu et
qu'on puisse nous aussi élu pouvoir
réagir de façon très positive
assez assez désespoir de personnes voilà
donc nul doute que voilà on va faire
réagir à à jean taibi à ces propos que
vous venez d'entendre sur les relations
entre les élus et la et la police au
quotidien elle et comment elle elle
ressemble à quoi as tu un dans votre
commune
eh ben elle est concrète je les
rencontre quasiment tous les jours que
ce soit une réunion mensuelle avec le
commissaire ça peut peut-être surprendre
monsieur cabaret quand je vais rebondir
après sur la question des drames this
year et puis sur la question aussi des
moyens que je réclame depuis de très
nombreuses années pour qui est beaucoup
plus de moyens de police y as ta matière
d'égalité avec l'eau du bain
nouveau pour nous moquons de policiers
déjà
certainement que monsieur cabaret et
doit le savoir il ya eu un rapport
extrêmement intéressant à pourparlers
menteur d'ailleurs qu'il a été rédigé
par un de vos à nouveau un de vos
collègues le rapport qui met en lumière
je dirais l'échec de la république en
seine-saint-denis en matière de en
matière de sécurité en matière de
justice et en matière d'éducation je
vous rassure c'était chez que en matière
de sécurité ne doivent pas depuis
l'arrivée de maquereaux il faut être là
dessus résonnaient les mêmes
malheureusement et c'est elle s'est
aggravée elles datent depuis qu' un
certain président sarkozy a décidé je
dirais de supprimer des milliers de
postes avec sa politique de l'algérie
rgpp c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
il a supprimé des postes au sein des
différents services publics des corps
constitués que je sois la police ou la
gendarmerie et ça a été fatale pour des
villes comme star pour des villes
populaires je pense que c'est vous
certainement aussi le cas en province
avec la gendarmerie d'auch qu'on a on a
payé très cher ici à stains je dirais le
fait qu'ils aient passé policiers n'ont
pas ces policiers il faut aussi des
policiers extrêmement fort mais parfois
les policiers sont formés en quelques
mois alors que parfois il faut des
cursus de formation qui soit beaucoup
plus long et qui soit aussi adapté au
reste du territoire donc à côté de ça
moi j'ai aucun souci travaille avec la
police il se fait au quotidien que ce
soit avec mon commissaire avec les
réunions mensuelles que ce soit avec eux
le commandant du commissariat ou avec
les agents de la police je rappelle que
j'ai une police municipale aussi un
stand et nos politiques la police
municipale et la police nationale
travaillent je dirais total
d'intelligence en symbiose ensemble et
ça ne m'empêche pas en effet 2 aussi je
dirais de me lever face aux violences
policières qui existent et qui sont le
fait de certains policiers jeu précis de
pâtes ou les policiers ça existe tout
comme je me lève le face aux violences
qui peuvent exister dans les quartiers à
l'encontre des policiers je suis bien
placé pour savoir parce qu'avant d'être
mère j'ai des éducateurs et je travaille
sur les quartiers et j'ai passé mon
temps j'ai passé le 20 ans de ma vie
professionnelle à créer les conditions
d'apaisement à j'étais un petit peu le
voilà entre les autres les deux le
pompier eu un peu le pompier de service
pour calmer et d'un côté les jeunes qui
vont en découdre avec la police y est
avec les policiers suite à des contrôles
suite à deux choses et puis d'un autre
côté avec certains policiers ont menti
dans lequel mais vous il faut discuter
et cetera donc quand je parle de leur
fondation en tous les cas de réformer la
police et la police c'est justement de
faire en sorte que la police soit un
sujet je dirais partager un objet
politique partagée en effet par les
institutions que représenta police mais
aussi par la population je pense que
c'est important les élus et vous l'avez
dit monsieur monsieur cabaret les élus
ont un rôle majeur à jouer là dessus les
élus les associations des différentes
forces vives qui sont solidairement pour
justement les syndicats bien évidemment
mais pas que les syndicats et d'arrivée
d'ailleurs tous les syndicats il
faudrait et je pense que même il
faudrait certainement arrêter d'écouter
certains représentants de syndicats qui
donc n'ont qu'une j'ai bien une ambition
c'est de mettre la pression sur les
gouvernements qui se sont succédé et en
particulier sur les ministres de
l'intérieur pour leur dicter un petit
peu la loire une orientation politique à
l'échelle gouvernementale elle m'a dit
vous faites allusion j'imagine au grand
oral qui s'est tenue mercredi
policiers alliance et trois candidats
marine le pen eric zemmour on rappelle
que les candidats de gauche ont décliné
l'invitation jean luc mélenchon lui n'a
pas été invité pierre cabaret justement
au cours de ces échanges est revenu à
plusieurs reprises ce lien qu'ont fait
certains candidats entre
police
et justice il est revenu aussi cette
expression de violence policière vous en
parliez tout à l'heure vous l'a décriée
ainsi jeu j'ai bien compris vous je
pense couple pourtant emmanuel macron
lui même avait admis et repris cette
expression de violence policière il a eu
tort
je pense que il a repris l'expression
d'un sens de violence de certains
policiers ce que l'on peut concevoir
aussi et il y a eu des violences
certainement de certains policiers comme
il ya des abus dans chaque profession et
on le voit bien aujourd'hui y compris
dans les ehpad mais donc
cette cette image de violences
policières qui concernerait chaque
policiers dans les manifestations
et qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
extrêmement dure vis-à-vis d'eux et est
extrêmement injuste vis-à-vis d'une
population moi j'adore charest oui
effectivement j'ai décrit donc mais moi
j'en fais pas une affaire politique
surtout parce que la politique les gens
en ont ras le bol vous savez ce qu'ils
veulent ce sont des ce sont des actes
essentielle et
non sur sa l'un des thèmes de cette
corbeille présidentielle c'est la
sécurité quel bilan est ce que
voudraient se rayer du quinquennat
macron ben je pense que c'est un bilan
qui évolue vers le mieux donc déjà c'est
déjà c'est une bonne chose ensuite c'est
une un bilan qui évolue vers la prise en
charge de chacun donc qui peut
s'exprimer et qui doit s'exprimer
ensuite je j'entendais tout à l'heure
monsieur monsieur le maire qui disait la
formation quelques mois non monsieur le
maire la formation d'un policier un
policier national
c'est une année et je reconnais qu
effectivement il faut mettre l'accent
sur cette formation continue mais cette
formation continue il faut mettre
l'accent aussi sur le fait de pouvoir
partager
continuellement ses expériences et y
compris les plus douloureuses au sein du
groupe et ça je crois c'est une action
c'est une des volontés du gouvernement
actuellement c'est une volonté de de
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur de
pouvoir
objective et c'est ces choses là non pas
directement vers toujours les
psychologues mais mes verres aussi
l'ensemble des collègues aujourd'hui le
lien si la chose la plus important si ça
la chose qui doit rassembler mais ça la
chose qui doit aider et protéger si le
lien ce lien là il faut le retrouver il
faut retrouver ce lien dans la police
mais il fut réclamé ce lien entre la
police et aussi la population et il ne
faut pas négliger aussi que ya certaines
populations qui ont une haine de la
police et il faut revendiquer que ces
populations piste être punis lorsqu'ils
pratiquent ce genre de choses parce que
ça n'aide personne et ça n'aide surtout
pas les policiers dans leur travail et
ni la justice dont le sien aussi et je
ne m'opposerai pas la police et la
justice alors sur ce point du lien
nécessaire entre la police et sa
population je pense que vous êtes en
phase al-din taibi avec ce qui vient
d'être d'être dit quelles sont les
grandes propositions de votre candidat
jean-luc mélenchon c'est sur ce thème de
la vérité ce sera le mot de la fin
avant de vous faire part des grandes
propositions proposée par jean luc
mélenchon et par le programme à venir en
commun d'abord il faut pour répondre à
monsieur cabaret il faut savoir que
celles et ceux en tout cas ceux qui ont
des postures de haine violente à la
police sont je dirais sont directement
jugé en tout cas
ne faisait pas croire que ne faites pas
croire justement que c est ce qui qui
ont des comportements violents ou
haineux envers la police ne sont pas
forcément julie sont jugés et même très
très sévèrement jugé le ferry
malheureusement n'est pas toujours le
cas ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
dans le sens inverse pour pour des
policiers maintenant dans les grandes
propositions dans des grands axes
communs que propose jean luc mélenchon
et pour lequel on a été très nombreux à
travailler d'abord le retour une police
de proximité ça c'est extrêmement
important je pense que là la gérer
l'efficacité de la bac de la bible parts
égales anti criminalité
à je dirais et plus qu'on est plus que
j'ai déjà dans une situation d
souplement moi je vois sur ma ville et
ce quart étoile à saint denis donc il
faut passer de mon point de vue à une
police vraiment de proximité des agents
qui sont prêts sur le terrain
sont outillés qui sont à je dirais
d'équipé pour travailler sur le terrain
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qui me semble vraiment importante
je rejoins dessus cabaret c'est de créer
toutes les conditions pour vraiment
tisser du lien très fort entre les
usagers entre les citoyens et la police
l'autre point important de mon point de
vue et jean luc mélenchon l'a déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises ces abroger toutes
les lois sécuritaires qui n'ont eu
aucune efficacité si ce n'est de créer
encore plus je dirais dans une telle
confusion entre le glas sécuritaire qui
parfois se confondent avec des lois je
dirais contrôler le terrorisme etc donc
on est très vite dans un an
bascule très vite dans un terrain qui en
réalité n'est pas la prochaine n est pas
là n'est pas la préoccupation première
en matière de sécurité mais plutôt une
préoccupation de stigmatiser plus de
populations de différents quartiers bon
je pense que toutes les lois
sécuritaires et je sais que me que le
présent mâcon ne les partage pas
forcément je serais assez surpris que le
présent bac on partage les lois
sécuritaires qui ont été ainsi je dirais
mise en place à l'époque de de sarkozy
ortho ce dont je suis pas sûr et puis un
autre un autre élément important c'est
en effet de complètement référe réformer
l'igpn parce qu'il faut en tous les cas
dans toutes les enquêtes je dirais de de
violences policières dans toutes les
enquêtes et permettez moi de vous dire
que je vois pas trop de différence entre
violence policière et violences de
policiers il n'y a pas de voeux là
dessus quand on parle de violence
policière ça ne craignait pas tous les
policiers 5 500 policiers et je voulais
à l'igpn
l'igpn de mon point de vue doit être
remplacée par une institution totalement
indépendante qui doit être unique a
complètement indépendante et pas
forcément sous le sous la sous la
coupelle d'autres policiers pour qu'elle
puisse en plus qu'a mené jusqu'au bout
son travail dans quête son travail je
dirais de façon je veux dire de façon
indépendante pour qu'ensuite je dis
merci pour se prononcer beaucoup
évidemment on aura l'occasion de revenir
en détail sur ses propositions en
matière de sécurité tout au long de
cette campagne présidentielle merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cet
échange has been taibi amer un pcr de ce
temps soutient jean luc mélenchon merci
à vous pierre un cabaret députés à la
république en marchant en haute garonne
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin de cette édition se retrouve à
21h pour un nouveau journal à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
faut-il effacer la dette détenue par la
bce est ce que c'est vraiment
juridiquement faisable c'est pas un
problème juridique c'est un problème est
quand même des actions sont possibles il
faut un peu